two weeks ago with christa stefano one
guy had his ass
he said cowboy [ __ ] and he was
impregnating a cow oh that's right and
we were throwing out our theories how
that happens and this guy
gives us an explanation of how cows are
impregnated okay
david here from mystic hill farm what's
up david originally became alexander
louisiana i'm not live man
i'm also a part of that nub club oh
damn that double up them rabbit ears
baby gang bro
hey theo since you neglected us they
were debating last week how to breed a
cow so i figured i'd give you a little
demonstration
oh first things first i'm the greatest
but these are semen tanks they've heard
some of the greats
we fill them with liquid nitrogen to
keep them cold so we can preserve
preserve them you pull up this can here
and there's your semen oh your canes
you pull one of them straws out but i
ain't gonna do it cause i ain't gonna
waste 50 dollars
you take one of them straws and you run
it over here
it's usually filled up with water at a
certain temperature you put it in there
boop
set your timer for a minute people say
45 seconds
but i do a minute i like it hot sets you
up right here
injecting that cow that's hot this is
awesome you got your gun here
you pull the plunger back you get your
semen
you cut the tip off you put your semen
in there
you put your sleeve on oh yeah
and then you stick this in your shirt
because it's usually cold and fall when
we breathe
you let it warm up then you put your
glove on and get you a little pump a
lube
and then you're ready to breathe you
pull this on out
you stick your arm up her ass brandon
okay and you're feeling around for that
cervix once you got the cervix
you slip this up in her vagina
oh yeah and then you feel for the front
of the
cervix once you get it in that's the
hardest part
it's just like an apple another ring
it's either two or three rings i can't
remember
but once you're out you'll feel a little
give
and you're going to shoot half to the
right horn
and then half to the left horn hey man
baby and then she's bread
wow anyways thank you for everything
y'all do
man y'all get me through the hay season
i love everything i listened to this
past weekend
um food diaries or
damn that's all right
damn food damn dude diaries bro that
dude is putting seed in animals bro yeah
he is man
pregnant a lot of cows that was a legit
breakdown wouldn't it
and all one shot that was incredible
really effective that guy
wow uh are we sending him five hundred
dollars
he's going to be fine i think he'll be
fine do you think
you could do ins insagnate a animal
right now
i would love to melcutel but as far as
getting
elbow deep in a cow's ass or vagina
probably a pass huh why you couldn't
handle it you think
it's just a lot it's messy isn't it i
don't know
i never know i don't know either i don't
know could you guys do it
hell no i think you'd do it it'd be
gross yeah
nick could definitely they could do it
yeah they could do it yeah nick seems
like a guy that does it
no judgment against it i've always
wanted to do fear factor i just feel
like
most of those things are mental and yeah
i'll do it i'll stick my hand up there
you could about you could guzzle like
the donkey sperm and stuff like that
that's like that was the worst one but i
think i got him kicked off the ear
kicked off the air oh i couldn't have
more than one sip no
yeah just a shot for me oh i don't even
know a
shot bro it'd have to be a shot i
couldn't slurp it like a slurpee
i'd have to be stall i'd have to not eat
for two days and then try it
that's fair if it was like real cold on
a hot summer day
hmm yeah i would need a strategy
yes to ingest it can't be just a
lukewarm what about that kid what about
bone marrow you do it
meat bone whatever that is g.h you gonna
you can you uh
take down some semen what would you
could you down some uh
donkey semen like a big cup of it donkey
semen
yeah they did on fear factor got him
kicked off the air depends like am i
going to get like absolutely shredded
after
what yeah yeah you are bucko
yeah it's worth it let's find out yeah
it'll be a quarter horse by tuesday man
you're going to be great
um yeah we'll see we'll see you in the
preakness
[Music]
[Music]